Sharon and I wrote a book about anger
basically and about the problem of
enmity and enemies and people feeling
they have them and being angry and
hating them and then killing each other
and so on so we thought it was a good
time to write a book about it and it
started out by being which we called it
working with your enemies and then we
decided that a lot of people might not
like to work with them so we we decided
to be more challenging and then we saw
this thing on a on a church front
billboard where they advertised the
Sunday sermon you know that in country
churches and it said love your enemies
because it will drive them crazy the
conceptualization of the book actually
came from a Tibetan Buddhist teaching so
bob was very my co-author Bob Thurman
was very instrumental in conceiving it
and this concept of enemies is is very
interesting all in in and of itself it's
been funny because as I've done a little
bit of work with the book and toured a
little bit with the book the word
enemies has really ignited some concern
on the part of people and it really just
means that which we have enmity toward
which we hold as fearful separate that
we feel really terribly alienated from
and so it could be a person it could be
a force within ourselves it could be a
habit it could be just a life situation
like suffering or getting ill or
something like that so the four enemies
which make up the kind of arc of the
book are first of all outer enemies so
those are people who have hurt us or
threaten us or have hurt those when we
care about so it's kind of the obvious
more conventional meaning of enemies and
then inner enemies which is the second
are those forces that when they overtake
us so it's not a question of just
feeling angry
or greed or jealousy but when we get
lost in them especially when they lead
to action which is often a regrettable
they function as enemies because they
just take us over and take us to a place
that might be really painful
the third enemy is the secret enemy in
this construct which is the construct of
self and other the way we feel that
we're not part of an interconnected
universe that we're a separate were
alone we're independent we need to be in
control we need to be all-powerful
because we don't see ourselves as part
of a whole and then the fourth enemy is
the super secret enemy which sometimes
is called self preoccupation Bob in this
book has been calling it self-loathing
I really think of it as a kind of
hopelessness where we try and try and
try to be happy but we may be doing it
in all the wrong ways very selfishly
very much from a cut-off place and
natural place of generosity or caring
and so we get more and more unhappy we
dislike ourselves even more and then we
just kind of feel defeated
so those are the four enemies
you